[Music]
working late yep
[Music]
the key to burning and ex-wife effigy is
to dip it in paraffin wax and then toss
the flaming bottle of isopropyl alcohol
from a safe distance
do not stand too close when you light an
ex-wife effigy no I don't plan to buy
anything here
I buy my burger and agree dance at food
and stuff a discount food outlet
equidistant from my home and my work I
came here for the same reason people go
to the zoo look at that
nature is amazing I love food and stuff
it's where I buy all of my food and most
of my stuff
ok everyone shut up and look at me
welcome to visions of nature this room
has several paintings in it some are big
some are small people did them and they
are here now I believe that after this
is over they'll be hung in government
buildings why the government is involved
in an art show is beyond me I also think
it's pointless for a human to paint
scenes of nature when they could just go
outside and stand in it anyway please do
not misinterpret the fact that I am
talking right now as genuine interest in
art and attempt to discuss it with me
further end of speech
happy birthday run and said you had a
big party sombreros karaoke he did that
for an why would I throw Ron Swanson an
Ann Perkins party what about the giant
list of things April was doing that was
just a list of ways to mess with you she
do them all she did indeed so I have
rented bridge on the river kwai and the
Dirty Dozen RT from security is outside
the door so no one will bother you and a
cab will be here whenever you're ready
to take you home thank you
I won't publicly endorse a product
unless I use it exclusively and I really
believe in it my only official
recommendations are u.s. army issued
mustache trimmers morton's salt and the
CR Lawrence find 2 inch x style scraper
oscillating knife blade this is your
lunch now you should be able to do
whatever you want to with this right if
you want to eat all of it great if you
want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here I come
the government and I get to take 40% of
your lunch and that Lauren is how taxes
work that's not fair
you're learning uh-oh capital gains tax
there's a sign at ramsett park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made Sun tea with it and now I have an
infection sir sir are are you are you
are you listening to me sir sir I'm
talking to you sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
I think if you would know one thing
about me it would be that I prefer
laying wreaths to lighting torches I
have cried twice in my life once when I
was seven and I was hit by his school
bus and then again when I heard that
little Sebastian had passed I have
accrued 228 personal days starting right
now I'm using all of them while I'm gone
you're in charge
also I keep a sizeable supply of ground
chuck in my desk remove it or it will
begin to smell Godspeed
okay so here's what's going on I didn't
I'm supposed to announce that I'm
running for City Council and I haven't
told Ben yet I know I said that we broke
up but we couldn't we're still dating
but now I have to break up with him for
real but I don't want to break over them
cuz he's so cute he's so nice if you're
gonna stay here there are three rules
you need to follow one no talk about
Tammy one - no talk about Ben three no
talk I didn't even ask you last night
what is going on with Tammy one just
violated rules number one and three you
lose your coffee privileges most of
these aren't even receipts this one says
I bought supplies 2007 you won't find
any bank statements either
I've heavily invested in gold which I've
buried in several different locations
around Pawnee or have I usually I only
read nautical novels and my own personal
manifestos but I'm proud to make this
exception thank you Ron
when people get too chummy with me I
like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know I don't really care about
them that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome
Lester thanks Ron you're welcome Steve
for the last three years I have served
as troop leader of the Pawnee Rangers
this is our handbook I wrote the whole
thing myself
on principle I never say anything that
another person is obviously trying to
get me to say my first wedding ceremony
took two hours because after the priest
said repeat after me
I felt silent
this forum like all public forums is a
waste of time thank you Swanson's are
you prepared for whatever lies ahead yes
before we proceed do any of you have any
dietary restrictions correct you do not
first outing is right now I will be
teaching you to dig a proper trench does
that sound like something you want to do
yes sir this will be no fun at all
in my experience wedding presents are
nothing more than kindling on the
divorce bonfire do you at least tell me
what you're doing I'm a homeowner I
would like to actually learn something
yeah I'm tightening the valve stem into
the valve shank I'm replacing the handle
and then tightening the set screw will
hold it in place no oh my god that's a
good feeling
sense of accomplishment and pride damn
it I just love it so much are you okay
great I'm gonna go around this house and
fix everything I can find that needs
fixing you want to help I really do good
that's next
flutes are $80 apiece and recorders are
150 hey there beautiful would you take a
check you can cash it tomorrow
sure what religion am i well I'm a
practicing none of your business
Ron you want to join us look I'll let
you be America and teach kids that not
only is government good but that there
should be a worldwide super government
I'd rather sand down my toenails every
three weeks I have to sand down my
toenails they're too strong for clippers
to this day some feminists have even
condemned marriage as a glorified form
of slavery amen
there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to google earth and type
in your address every year I give Leslie
the same present I give everyone a crisp
$20 bill and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal that
makes me furious this year she outdid
herself she had it installed over the
weekend so it's so beautiful
I don't want to paint with a broad brush
here but every single contractor in the
world is a miserable incompetent thief
Ron Swanson just the man I wanted to see
I'm going to be going to a seminar on
the art of the Japanese tea ceremony or
check ie at the Pawnee Community College
and I thought you might like to come
with me why it is this this is a great
friend of mine he is a fellow who works
in the building and he is named dan iel
hey Ron thanks for coming man of course
this bowling alley has my favorite
restaurant in Pawnee
really you're not scared to eat her when
I eat a bit of scared
you